hbo sports presents the weight of gold a
revealing documentary exploring the
mental health challenges olympic
athletes often face
in very personal detail it debuts
tonight at nine eastern
and pacific the film features michael
phelps who's also the narrator and
executive producer lolo jones
jeremy bloom is in there body miller
apollo um
ono is also in there sean white is in
there
it seeks to inspire the discussion of
mental health encourage help seeking
behavior
and highlight the need for readily
available help and support and michael
phelps the most decorated olympian of
all time
joins us on the program i'll get to the
documentary in a moment
but michael have you ever had a job
that wasn't swimming related
i don't think so i was laughing you guys
were talking about that no i i don't
think i really have done anything
but swim or i guess talk
but not even a life guard no
paper boy mo mo yards deliver pizzas
nope you know what you should do
you should do a show where you do some
of these jobs
for the first time like chef
you mow somebody's grass
i did mow grass as a kid and i do cook
every day so i guess those are kind of
okay all right
what did you put on exploring my options
what did you put on your taxes
for your profession um
uh my financial advisor filled that up
but but were you uh
so you didn't even do that
so do you think he put down swimmer
athlete oh athlete all right uh
this is a powerful documentary and i
know you've been at the forefront of
talking about depression and and
we don't see this and i'm glad you
brought it to the forefront
you spent all your life to do something
and it could be for two minutes it could
be for one race it could be for just a
moment there
and then all of a sudden you have to get
on with your life after that
but what has your life been prior to
that other than being just that athlete
was what i took out of it um when did
you realize
you know like kind of who am i now
because you weren't a swimmer
you'd become michael phelps you know
husband father
that's a big big realization right i
guess like the biggest thing was
was you know really learning to love who
i saw in the mirror
you know i mean for you know as you
heard in the documentary like i
i truly thought of myself and felt felt
like i was just a swimmer and not a
human being
not a person um and that was you know
i guess a lot a lot because i felt like
i couldn't share some of the things that
i had carried throughout my career
because
in in the sports world like we can't
show a weakness
and if we show a weakness then we're
giving something away to our competitors
and that's something that that
you obviously try to want to stay away
from and and you know it took me a long
time to realize that
there are other ways to go about this
and and you know i think after
after competing in my fifth olympics and
in rio and and seeing there were other
athletes that were going through similar
things
uh i i was startled
shocked surprised uh but also scared
um and and felt like uh i needed to step
up and
and try and talk about this and very
thankful to have the other athletes step
up and show their vulnerability and
share the stories that they have as well
but you get to that point when you
reveal something really
personal and i'd gone through something
a year ago
where i mentioned on the show that i'd
battle i battled depression
and you know people think you have
everything like what are you depressed
about
and then you have to explain to people
depression doesn't know what you've
accomplished
it just sort of taps you on the shoulder
but
you had you had to have that moment
where you go
i'm going public with this yeah i mean i
think for me it was
just like uh it was almost just annoying
just to kind of have it like
keep coming up keep coming up and
feeling like i couldn't deal with it and
and i finally got to the point where i
was like you know what this is this is
who i am and
and this makes me um so you know i think
uh you know once i realized that
depression or anxiety is going to be a
part of my life forever
um i i decided to start learning more
about it and that's where
you know i felt comfortable and safe
opening up and
and talking about my struggles and and
you know i still
i still talk about them today i'm still
going through them today i mean i'm sure
a lot of people are going through
similar things during this pandemic as
well
you and kevin love really i think open a
lot of people's
eyes to this uh run our test going back
when he was playing for the lakers just
to be able to share that so people
understand
anybody can go through this it's the
question is is somebody listening to you
and and you have somebody to talk to i
don't know you probably
didn't share this when you were an
olympian with anybody did you
no i mean i think the the first time i
really opened was
probably well i guess it was right
before 16. um 2014 i opened up in a
sports illustrated interview with tim
layden and and whatever question he
asked it just it triggered something
and and made me feel safe to open up and
and ever since that i haven't looked
back and truly um
i've been able to find that
communicating uh has been the
single-handed thing that
that truly has saved my life um i feel
like i
i learned it later in life than i would
have liked to but at least i learned it
so
you know communicating for me is
something that i try to do more of every
single day because that's the way that i
can learn and grow and
and try to become a better person how
dark did it get for you
i mean a few times it's been pretty dark
where you know you almost don't want to
see
you know the next day but you know i i
will
say that i think through the journey
that i've been through so far
um i i have been able to experience
more during these last four to six
months than i ever could imagine
um you know i feel like going through
this pandemic that we're in
where we don't you know i guess we have
so many uncertainties
um i i truly feel like i've been able to
have
challenges placed almost like
strategically through this
for me to go through and and you know i
feel like my wife has
my wife and i have really been able to
um
become closer and learn more about uh i
guess each other and i think just
just the communicating that we've had
through this this process has been
um obviously very challenging but um
life-changing and something i'm thankful
for
what role do your children play in this
oh my gosh my children no matter what
they do will
automatically bring a pure smile
the biggest smile joy to my face um
they're up right now i can hear them in
the background going crazy and you know
truly it's it's it's nothing but just
absolutely um
happiness i mean it's it's sometimes
it's frustrating when they press
it press your buttons my oldest knows
how to press mine
very well um give me an example give me
an example
um you know like the i i guess it's
like i remember myself as a kid growing
up asking why
i you know like you ask a question and i
don't know the answer to it so i say i
don't know the answer to it and he says
why
why why why why and like i don't know i
have no idea why
like one day you'll understand um but
but you know i think
it's just it's so awesome to see and to
hear the things that they say
um i mean it surprises me every single
day i would
you got to remove the word why as a
parent i would remove the word
why from my kids vocabulary and you have
three i have four but they're grown
and there'd be times i would just say go
ask your mom like i didn't know what the
answer was i just said go ask your mom
you know and that they'd go ask her and
she said go ask your dad
like it was like a game of tennis you
know with that word back and forth yeah
that's so good
uh we're talking to michael phelps the
documentary is weight of gold it's
tonight
at 9 eastern on hbo 9 eastern and
pacific
what would you change about the olympic
system that could help
athletes well people become a person
uh in everyday life um is there
something that would stand out
yeah i mean i think you know you hear us
talk a lot in the film about it's okay
to not be okay
you know i think that's something that
that we can all learn and really take to
heart and
and and also you know i mean if you're
having a hard time talk about it
you know like i i i truly was able to
see firsthand in rio how many other
athletes were struggling from this and
and
you know 80 of people i i would say
coming out of an olympics will go
through some kind of depression and and
you know in in the states it's one and a
half or one
one out of every five go through some
kind of mental health struggle so
um yeah it's it's uh it's wild it's
crazy i mean
how do you feel that that competitive
void
uh i'm on the golf course a lot so all
right
i'm not very good but i'm still uh
i'm still working out so i'm still
challenging myself that way i work out
six or seven days a week still and
um trying to get that going but yeah i
think golf is something that that
you know as athletes take on it's
something that is challenging to perfect
so i've had the chance to play with some
pretty amazing people out there and
learn a lot so hopefully i can
improve my game but i don't know and i
hear you lose money when you play too
yeah i have a couple times yeah now do
you pay
cash to the president uh president uh
barack obama
or is it a check a medal like like a
bronze or something
he was good he had good hands man oh my
gosh he did not miss a single putt out
there
um it's uh it i i remember exactly
what i lose to each person so i hope to
have the chance to
win that back at some point in my life
um so
if they're listening i i i remember it
um and i'm coming back for it
what's the day after the olympics like
uh for me it was going home um i mean i
it's always challenging to be on the
being on the road for two to three
months so
for me i want to get out of there and
and i remember in rio i just
i went right to the hotel room where my
wife and son were and
spent time with them but also you have
all of this
build up and all these races and
everybody is everybody cares about
these sports that they don't care about
at any other time other than the
olympics they're all
in the pressure the united states
are you going to have you know how many
gold med like
there's a lot going on and then all of a
sudden it's over and then you go
okay now what yeah you basically twiddle
your thumbs and either you're gonna
start back for another four years
or you're going to start the next
chapter of your life and and
that's either finding a job um or it's
hoping to take a can of pulled off of
what you've done in your career and
and you know for me i'll say fortunate
i've been extremely lucky to have a
decent career where
you know i can take that and and help me
into the next transition
don't don't do fake humility that's
you're better than that
i mean look i mean looking back i i
would have liked another
you know had another world record or so
but you know i i
i had a great career i did and and it
was fun
but yeah what race bothers you because
guys of yours
with your success they always talk about
the ones that got away
they don't always talk about the ones
that they want um
400 i am from 2012 200 fly from 2012.
i'd like to have 100 100 or 200 back
redo again and maybe give
that world record a chance i mean there
are a handful of races i i would
definitely do again did you ever have a
perfect race
yeah i mean i i would say the 400 i am
from 2008 the 200 free from 08 was
pretty good
um yeah other than that
i can always pick something to to
depict from a race so the olympics are
you know pushed back to 2021 and
you and paulie my producer have had a
ongoing bat about paulie thinks you're
coming back to swim
looking good mike yep he looks like he's
in shape paulie right
cleanly 2021 happened i don't know
if if if it does will you be there
in swimming trunks maybe in the hotel
pool
if you if you could compete today could
you compete today with the top swimmers
in the world
at this very minute yeah probably not no
how about a mon
how about six months
no oh okay so this is it i mean like
honestly like if i like if i really
wanted to do it
in a perfect way i would need a minimal
18 to 24 months
um just i mean it's it's hard to
like assuming you take one day it takes
two days to get back
so like i've been swimming a little bit
here and there now but i
i don't feel like i know how to swim
when i jump in the pool i i feel like
i'm just learning again so
i've lost a lot of feel for the water oh
man if i wanted to yeah i feel like i
could in 18 to 24 months but
i don't think i don't think it's gonna
happen when's the last time you jumped
in the pool even with your kid like did
has somebody challenge you anytime you
jump in the pool
do you have people say come on let's
let's let me swing against you uh
i'll have yeah from time to time you'll
have somebody who will push off like as
i'm doing a flip turn and try to race
you for a 25
um so you end up just taking three or
four strokes and
pulling away or i i hammer a turn and
do four or five pick outs to make sure
that they know that i'm not playing
around
[Laughter]
yeah but it's all the time i mean it's
non-stop my kids are in the pool every
single day so
they've got a mean stream line right now
and boomer's got some nice freestyle
going
that's great hey it's great to talk to
you and i know it
sounds strange to say this michael but
you know what
we may look back on what you've done
with this
more than what you did in a pool and i i
hope so i mean i honestly i think
you know i i this is in my opinion
bigger than anything i've ever done in
the pool
um bigger than winning a gold medal and
and honestly you know i
i i know how hard it is to go through
something like this and and
um i've dealt with it for a long time
and i still go through it so
um you know the people who are out there
you know struggling you're not alone
um you know you got somebody sitting in
arizona
uh pretty much every day that has some
kind of
some kind of struggle so um you know
keep your head up and and
one step after another and and i ask for
help you know it's something that that
truly did save my life and and
hopefully we can really start to lower
the suicide numbers
the weight of gold it's a revealing
documentary it's powerful and it's not
just michael talking about this
jeremy bloom lolo jones is in there
gracie gold bode miller
uh apollo ono is in there and uh
michael is the executive producer the
narrator and it seeks to inspire
discussion of mental health and
uh encourage help seeking behavior and
that's really what michael's getting to
boy it's great when you have somebody
who would just sit and listen to you
because there are times when you feel
like nobody understands exactly what
you're going through so
michael it's great to talk to you again
swimming starts in
a year in four days in the olympics
paulie just throwing it out there i saw
the schedule
okay i think michael's retired i do
would you swim paulie my producer
um would it be a swimming race uh
it would well what do what constitutes a
rain
this isn't a katie ledecky i'm gonna
beat you by
you know an entire lap or something yeah
i mean i'm sure we could we could set
something up it could be interesting
how about floaties i could deck you out
with some great mp gear
bollywood wear that i would wear that
michael you ever raced like a 12 meter
medley because that's kind of my max
i don't know if i would take a breath i
think i would just shoot the other side
of the pool
how long can you go without taking a
breath uh
well i'll answer the question but i have
to say i don't do it very often because
it's not safe but when i do do it it's
because i've been practicing um
i can probably go 100 meters underwater
up and back in a 50 meter pool but
that's just
honestly again we've spent a lot of time
in the water and
i'm probably more comfortable in that
pool or in water than i am on land
paulie you want to wear nose plugs does
mp make nose plugs mike i get a little
in my nasal i don't think phelps has a
nose plug but
um i mean we could probably find one for
you we'll get the
you know the synchronized swimmers they
have those
there you go what stroke would you go
with though yeah what would you go with
paulie
uh i don't have any i would have to
watch some tape
i would probably do backstroke because
then i could actually breathe
do we have odds on this oh i don't think
vegas is going to touch this michael
i don't think vegas will can we bound
your legs your feet
and have you swim can we
can we put cement shoes on suit of armor
yes good handicap there yeah
uh hey great to talk to you good luck
with the documentary and uh
and happy for you with the the kids as
well thank you michael here's your buddy
jetson
that's uh michael phelps he's not coming
back paulie he is not coming back you're
going to lose your bet there
the documentary is weight of gold it's
tonight at 9 eastern and pacific